the White House spent all weekend
pushing back against the new book that
repeatedly claims President Trump is
unfit for office the president's allies
blitz the Sunday news shows to counter
quotes from some of his closest aides
who said he's unstable and ill-equipped
for the presidency the author Michael
Wolfe is in studio 57 this morning we'll
hear from him in just a moment but first
Margaret Brennan is at the White House
with the response that started at the
top Margaret good morning good morning
well the president spent a working
weekend at Camp David aimed laying out
the Republican legislative agenda
including immigration reform but he
repeatedly took time out in combative
style to rebut a scathing review of a
book about him I consider it a work of
fiction with Republican allies beside
him president Trump displayed his own
fire and fury over Michael Wolf's book
the author obtained scathing quotes from
former chief strategist Steve Bannon who
the president now refers to as sloppy
Steve's that's why sloppy Steve is now
looking for a job on Sunday Bannon tried
to walk back his remarks specifically
that Donald Trump juniors June 2016
meeting with Russians to obtain damaging
information on Hillary Clinton was
treasonous in a statement he claimed
those comments were not aimed at Don
junior but rather aimed at Paul Manafort
the Trump campaign chairman who had also
attended the meeting throughout the book
the president is characterized as
semi-literate and having a problem with
reality investor and longtime friend Tom
Barrack is cited as saying he is not
only crazy he's stupid Barrack since
denied that remark on Saturday mr. Trump
tried to brush off damaging comments
attributed to economic adviser Gary
Cohen who allegedly said the president
is an idiot surrounded by clowns
Gary hopefully will be staying for a
long time and on Twitter the president
defended his mental fitness saying that
he is a quote genius and a very stable
genius at that the president's mental
state has been publicly questioned
before most notably by Republican
senator bob Corker president
been able to demonstrate the stability
nor some of the confidence
he needs to demonstrate and more
frequently by Democrats like California
congressman Adam Schiff we have a
seriously flawed human being in the Oval
Office across TV networks on Sunday the
president's allies came to his defense
perhaps none so vehemently as adviser
Stephen Miller as the president is a
political genius who won against a field
of 17 incredibly talented people after
that segment Miller was asked to leave
the set and according to a CNN source
refused to do so he was then escorted
out by security President Trump later
tweeted that the anchor who did the
interview was full of quote hatred and
unfairness which Nora suggests that the
President himself was watching Margaret
thanks